one that doesn't lose two-thirds of its power to waste heat,
as is today the case in the US.
We could use some more nuclear power, perhaps,
although it would have to be an entirely different kind of nuclear power,
because today's technology simply isn't cost-competitive
with renewable energy whose costs are falling so rapidly.
We'd need a new kind of plane,
because I don't think it's particularly practical
to ask the entire world to give up on air travel,
especially as so much of the global South
is, for the very first time, able to afford it.
We need planes that won't produce carbon.
We need a new kind of agriculture.
Because we probably can't ask people to entirely give up on meat and go vegan,
it would mean a new way of raising beef.
Or perhaps an old way,
since we already know that traditional pasturing practices
can turn cattle farms
from what are called carbon sources, which produce CO2,
into carbon sinks, which absorb them.
If you prefer a techno solution,
maybe we can grow some of that mean in the lab.
Probably, we could also feed some real cattle seaweed,
because that cuts their methane emissions by as much as 95 or 99 percent.
Probably, we'd have to do all of these things,
because as with every aspect of this puzzle,
the problem is simply too vast and complicated
to solve in any single silver-bullet way.
And no matter how many solutions we deploy,
we probably won't be able to decarbonize in time.
That's the terrifying math that we face.
We won't be able to beat climate change,
only live with it and limit it.
And that means we'd probably need
some amount of what are called negative emissions,
which take carbon out of the atmosphere as well.
Billions of new trees, maybe trillions of new trees.
And whole plantations of carbon-capture machines.
Perhaps an industry twice or four times the size
of today's oil and gas business
to undo the damage that was done by those businesses in past decades.
We would need a new kind of infrastructure,
poured by a different kind of cement,
because today, if cement were a country,
it would be the world's third biggest emitter.
And China is pouring as much cement every three years
as the US poured in the entire 20th century.
We would need to build seawalls and levees
to protect those people living on the coast,
many of whom are too poor to build them today,
which is why it must mean an end to a narrowly nationalistic geopolitics
that allows us to define the suffering of those living elsewhere in the world
as insignificant,
when we even acknowledge it.
This better future won't be easy.
But the only obstacles are human ones.
That may not be much of a comfort,
if you know what I know about human brutality and indifference,
but I promise you, it is better than the alternative.
Science isn't stopping us from taking action,
and neither is technology.
We have the tools we need today to begin.
Of course, we also have the tools we need to end global poverty,
epidemic disease
and the abuse of women as well.
Which is why more than new tools, we need a new politics,
a way of overcoming all those human obstacles --
our culture, our economics,
our status quo bias,
our disinterest in taking seriously anything that really scares us.
Our shortsightedness.
Our sense of self-interest.
And the selfishness of the world's rich and powerful
who have the least incentive to change anything.
Now, they will suffer too,
but not as much as those with the least,
who have done the least to produce warming
and have benefited the least
from the processes that have brought us to this crisis point
but will be burdened most in the decades ahead.
A new politics
would make the matter of managing that burden,
where it falls and how heavily,
the top priority of our time.
No matter what we do, climate change will transform modern life.
Some amount of warming is already baked in and is inevitable,
which means probably some amount of additional suffering is, too.
And even if we take dramatic action
and avoid some of these truly terrifying worst-case scenarios,
it would mean living on an entirely different planet.
With a new politics, a new economics,
a new relationship to technology
and a new relationship to nature --
a whole new world.
But a relatively livable one.
Relatively prosperous.
And green.
Why not choose that one?
Thank you.
(Applause)